what is happening right now with this
business model that was foisted upon us
can someone write this for her by the
way
can someone can someone stop it can
someone write this down for her because
she looks like erratic and she doesn't
know what's going on and this is not a
good communication strategy I understood
this is the way that they think actors
they're all like it's got to be all over
the place she's like the business model
is Chang that's but it's like you get
just let's let's hammer out points
couple of points couple of key points
point one point two point three point
four not this I'm all over the place I'm
screaming and yelling she looks like
she's about to break out in a song
it's like you gotta you know you gotta
just a little composure goes a long way